For ant questions, it was fine to convert our numbers from scientific notation
to being normal decimal numbers, and then multiply them together. But what if
the exponents were much bigger? We'd probably get lost in all the zeroes we'd
have to write, or at least I would. I think we need a better strategy. When
we're multiplying two numbers in scientific notation together, we can use
something we learned about very early on in this course. It's the commutative
property of multiplication. Let's see how this works. Let's say that we want to
multiply 2 times 10 to the negative 4th, by 3 times 10 to the 3rd again. Well,
the commutative property of multiplication says that we can rearrange the order
of any of these things we're multiplying together. What we actually have over
here, even though we have some grouping by parentheses right now, Is just four
numbers multiplied. Either ignore the parentheses and just say 2 times 3 and
then multiply that by the 10s but they're exponents. We can rearrange this so
that instead we multiply the 2 and the 3 together. And then we multiply the two
factors with the bases of 10. Now what is this equal to in scientific notation?
Think back to the start of the course again, when we talked about how to
combine exponents, when the base is the same.